so let's now go from the cultural war
question to one about rights and
responsibilities we talked about the
Trump administration turning coronavirus
into a cultural war because they have to
they're losing on the science so they're
making it a cultural war
now I want to focus in on the so-called
Liberty coronavirus protesters the
people talking about liberty and
government tyranny as the reasons why
states must open and masks must not be
worn and I need my hair dyed and all of
this stuff they are the ones talking
about why churches and restaurants and
hair salons must all be open right now I
have to tell you I'm sympathetic to
their desires
I'm simp want everything open as soon as
possible I believe we are only needing
to be disclosed because of early
failures by not just the Trump
administration but also many governors I
am skeptical of a total indefinite
shutdown as an even remotely reasonable
thing that could or should extend more
than a minimum amount of time it's bad
for people's mental health it's terrible
for the economy but the thing is I'm
regularly proving my level of
responsibility that would go with the
freedoms that I want and the problem is
that these protesters and the so called
tyranny people regularly prove they
can't be responsible with the freedom
they claim an absolute right to I don't
know if this idea originally came from
Eleanor Roosevelt but she once wrote
quote freedom makes a huge requirement
of every human being with freedom comes
responsibility for the person who is
unwilling to grow up the person who does
not want to carry his own weight this is
a frightening prospect restrictions on
freedom essentially stem from people
abusing freedoms and forcing a
restriction on those so called freedom
so let's really dig into it and
understand it first of all I want to be
clear when the gun people for the last
10 years that I've been doing the show
talked to me about government tyranny I
never imagined they were talking about
wearing a mask and staying home to watch
Netflix right that that we never
imagined that
actually what they were talking about
but let's take them at their word that
this is tyranny as they see it and it's
about the economy and it's about liberty
if everyone were responsible we wouldn't
need nearly as many restrictions when
you were talking about a virus a few
people can ruin it for everybody there's
one recent study which estimated 80
percent of the spread is caused by 9
percent of the people that are infected
in other words most people who have the
virus aren't infecting anyone they are
infecting zero people a small number of
people are infecting a whole bunch of
others now some of these are of course
not irresponsible behavior people that
are causing the spread but many of them
are and so the very people demanding
absolute and total freedom have in many
cases shown no evidence that they can
actually bear the responsibility that
comes with that freedom the same people
demanding everything reopen are often
the people continuing to have mass
gatherings hosting huge services at
their mega church refusing to wear a
mask as some kind of political statement
the reason governors had to put in place
restrictions and then stricter
restrictions and then stricter
restrictions is because simply
communicating the facts about the
disease didn't get people to act
responsibly so over time people work
from home masks become a requirement
businesses have to close supermarkets
have to put in place more and more
guidelines parks have to close
they only insist on their rights in a
total vacuum where their
responsibilities are not being met and
aren't even being discussed it is
petulant childish nonsense to simply say
my rights my rights my rights and
pretend that you have no
responsibilities to society and in fact
it's what Donald Trump does it's
mimicking Trump it's basically this I
wanna I wanna I wanna stuff and nothing
else matters
you're right to get your hair dyed so
that your roots don't show must happen
in the context of ensuring that you're
not getting people sick where there's
there when and where there is a deadly
virus spreading and so then they will
shift their bogus bad faith arguments
liberals want the economy closed they
want to hurt biz
maybe to hurt Donald Trump in November
find me an actual example with evidence
of someone who makes it clear they want
the economy hurt either for the sake of
hurting the economy or to hurt Donald
Trump or whatever I will be right there
with you and slamming them I've been
clear from day one Trump has long out
state as welcomed overstayed his welcome
in the White House we didn't need his
coronavirus failings we don't need a
higher death toll to justify removing
Donald Trump in November I don't want
anybody to lose their business or their
job or their life because of coronavirus
for a political statement but the
irresponsible people who talk only about
their rights as the reason why we are
here today every right comes with
another side of the coin the First
Amendment the right to free speech and
freedom of religion and right to
assemble until your assembling in a way
that infringes on others or using the
speech to incite violence use the right
responsibly the Second Amendment you
have the right to keep and bear arms of
course as long as you behave responsibly
in your life as long as you don't commit
certain crimes where you have to forfeit
your right to bear those arms the right
comes with responsibility the freedom of
my fists as the example goes to fly
around stops at your nose and if I don't
use that freedom responsibly I will be
in trouble so every time one of these
protesters is demanding their rights in
a vacuum with no discussion of the
responsibility that they will bring
let's hear from them what responsible
behavior they are bringing to the table
otherwise it's just BS and that's what
we're increasingly seeing make sure you
follow me on twitter at D Pakman and
remember this show has a daily hour-long
podcast if you watch on YouTube for
example you can get the full hour-long
audio podcast we're on stitcher we're on
iTunes we're on Spotify all of those
things subscribe free to the daily audio
podcast we'll take a break and be back
after this